krikey bindi Irwin is proving herself to
be an amazing big sister and Robert is
so snazzy tonight thank you thank you
yes on Sunday she posted an adorable
photo of her brother on Instagram in
celebration of his 16th birthday
alongside the throwback pic she wrote
quote it's incredible that Robert is 16
now time sure does fly also mom is the
most beautiful woman in the world
earlier in the day of the siblings
mother Terri Irwin posted a
never-before-seen photo of baby Robert
with his father Steve Irwin writing
quote your dad would be so proud of you
he has loved you since the moment you
were born the journey of life lost what
you might give it might ET has spent a
lot of time with the Irwin family over
the years as they've shared their
journey after Steve's tragic death in
2006 it's been over ten years now and
it's like the grief is always gonna be
that but I think that now it's moving
forward and remembering everything that
dad worked so hard for et's lauren zima
caught up with the Irwin's earlier this
year at the annual Steve Irwin gala
where they talked about their dad's
legacy Robert you you seem even older
and more mature like so quickly than
last year I feel like you'reyou're
growing up real fast do people compare
you to your dad a lot you look so much
like and you have as energy oh well when
when people say that you know you remind
us of your dad that's the biggest
compliment I could ever receive
definitely because this is what we've
dedicated our life to is making sure
that that that message that he had that
the passion that he had continues and
you know he really did change the world
he inspired us that's why we're so
passionate so it's yeah I feel very
lucky the position that I'm in but it's
interesting looking at some of the
photos of him when he was my age and you
can see it's it's very similar it's a
little bit freaky it's amazing
[Music]